Lucie Fink: As a content creator
with my own business online,
I'm normally someone who works from home,
but ever since the coronavirus outbreak
and the call to stay indoors,
not only has the type of content
that I'm producing shifted,
but also my workflow has shifted.
Ashley Ballard: Hey,
everybody. My name's Ashley.
Lucie: Hey, everyone, I'm Lucie Fink.
Coco Bassey: Hi, my name is Coco Bassey,
and I'm the founder and
creator of Millennielle.com.
Ashley: And I'm a blogger
and social-media editor
based in New York City.
Lucie: I'm a video producer
and lifestyle host,
and I run my own media company.
Coco: Normally on a day like this...
Ashley: I'd be going to the office
or checking out my favorite coffee shop.
Coco: I would be out
shooting content for brands,
maybe be taking a client out to lunch.
Ashley: But instead,
I'm cooped up by myself
in my Brooklyn apartment.
I've had a lot of privilege that
a lot of other people don't
necessarily get to have,
which is getting to work from home.
Coco: It's definitely not
ideal for creatives like me
that do most of our job outdoors.
Lucie: Often, I'm working
with a team of other people.
If I'm doing a high-quality video shoot
outside of my apartment,
sometimes I'll hire a
videographer or an audio expert.
When it comes to videographers
and photographers,
I have totally had to do
all of that on my own.
So a lot of what I'm shooting
is just setting up a camera on a tripod
or just leaning it against the windowsill
and shooting it myself.
At the start of this,
it was really tempting
to kind of just continue
creating content like normal,
but I've realized that right now
the world is just not normal.
And if you just avoid that
and don't talk about it,
people are not going to
find what you're saying
to be useful or relevant at all.
Coco: So, creating content at home
doesn't always have to
be this huge production,
and I think that's one of the things
that a lot of creators
kind of get stuck doing.
Like, when we are unable to get outside
and create this, like,
amazing, extravagant setup,
we think that we're, like,
unable to work at all,
and that's totally not true.
I have my iPhone,
my vlogging camera, which is a Canon G7 X,
and then I also have my DSLR camera
that I tend to use for some
of my bigger brand projects.
I will always make sure
that the camera is at my,
basically at my, like, hip or waist level
because that's kind of where
it looks the most flattering.
I don't like to go that much lower,
otherwise it kind of
feels like the camera's
looking up my nose [laughs],
which is not that great either.
Lucie: More and more
recently, I've found myself
gravitating towards shooting on my iPhone.
I don't have any of my
soft box lights with me,
so I've just been using windows
as a source of natural light.
Ashley: I usually have a tripod,
but since I left it at my office
before the quarantine happened,
I've been using a stack of
books on top of a stool.
This is A-OK if you don't own a tripod,
Like, you can totally improvise
with anything that you have.
Personally, I'm focused on
doing video-based content
because that is a way for
me to diversify my work
and connect with people better.
It also gives people more of an idea
of how I'm doing in my house
and, like, kind of what I'm working on.
And it makes me feel more
connected to the outside world.
Coco: So, when it comes
to experimental content,
I will definitely, without a doubt,
say that it's been getting into TikTok,
which is kind of crazy to think about.
I never thought that
I would be the creator
that would get into TikToks.
I just didn't think it
was a platform for me.
But I've seen some really,
really cool content on there,
and it's also kind of cool to play around
with video editing, which is something
I've always wanted to be better at.
Lucie: I started using
TikTok just as a fun outlet
for me to dance, and it
actually makes me sweat a lot.
And then people seemed
to like the TikTok stuff,
so I created a YouTube video tutorial
showing them how to do a
TikTok dance that I love.
I'm a savage.
Huh.
OK.
That's how it goes.
[laughing]
I'm not a dance instructor,
so I usually work with dance instructors.
And I've also been experimenting
with some quarantine-specific content.
So, cutting my husband's
hair in quarantine
and also my morning routine in quarantine.
And people seem to be
resonating with that as well.
Coco: Been doing a lot
more skin care and beauty.
I feel like now is the
time to get out there
and experiment with some
new products and stuff
and even play around with makeup,
'cause if you mess it up,
no one's gonna see it.
[laughs]
I feel like these times now
I have so much more time to
connect with my audience.
Ashley: It's easier said
than done, depending on
the size of your account,
but it's important
to be extra responsive to your audience.
A lot of people are probably coming to you
from a really anxious and unsure place.
Lucie: Digital connection is everything.
It's one of the only
ways that people are able
to stay connected with
their families and friends
that they're not with right now.
And, honestly, it's how people
are maintaining a lifeline
and a connection to the outside world.
Ashley: My No. 1 tip is
just finding the tool
that, like, gets you the
closest to your audience
that makes you feel comfortable.
One big thing that I've
been experimenting with more
is doing livestreaming
when I make my coffee in the morning
and I'm relaxing on my windowsill.
I just turn on my live,
and I just ask people how they're feeling.
Coco: I've been loving
running polls on my Instagram stories.
Lucie: Some of the ways that
I've connected with my audience
right now are by using the
sticker tab on Instagram.
That's a great way to hear
directly from your audience
in response to a targeted question.
I use my YouTube
community tab pretty often
as a way to ask questions
or to take polls.
Ashley: A lot of people are
turning to content right now
to just, you know, feel a
tiny ounce of normality.
Lucie: And if you do have
a platform with an audience
that's listening to you,
just use it right now
to spread some sort of positivity.